[Music]
today I'm here to dress my daughter and
I'm kind of excited about that it's kind
of kind I trust like his style and his
eye I think that like I have a certain
way I enjoy dressing and I don't
necessarily thinks he loves the way I
enjoy dressing we're very similar people
I potentially get my sense of style from
him he's generally an over-the-top
person and the apple definitely doesn't
fall too far from the tree sometimes she
doesn't mind wearing two different pairs
of socks I'm impressed with what she's
weird today because he matches her head
it's simple signs of a truly extravagant
person he just called my looks simple I
would say she should never wear the
skirt again
hey it also looks like a creepy on the
Duquesne ball it has baskets of fruit on
it where else are you gonna find skirts
I don't tell her what to wear what she
usually makes a good choice that you
know you could be proud of she's you
know got great legs you don't need to
see him all the time I'm going to go out
with you and work on you with this new
problem that you have I'm trying to look
extraordinaire really good I don't have
a problem looking ordinarily good it's
just nice if you were cleaner simpler
and a little more straightforward it may
be less skirty
and the adventure begins
wouldn't think about it you think it's
too manly yes
[Music]
so much there's being on the subway with
this thank you sorry excuse me ash Tina
sit down at the seat here I haven't won
earrings in a year we just put them up
there
I'm telling you right now is really
heavy
it goes with what you wearing right now
and
welcome to begin with everything in us
in a million years
[Music]
nice I think I hit it I'm wearing
clothing that is a fact what happened to
you yeah I'm sure listen man you man is
just like that take your glasses off for
a minute because it just doesn't look
right I don't like not being able to see
you worried leggings as pants this is
the second time I've ever used leggings
as pants in my entire life that's new
it's okay because I know that my butts
didn't leggings the leggings actually
show off your leg the shape of your legs
better than just skin so so I'm both
more covered up and like far more
scandalous cute I don't know if I would
have literally picked it out myself but
I don't oppose the look at all better
not opposing I think I look like
vacation mom I'm wearing my leggings and
like cut my comfy black shirt but also I
have my silver earrings on and my big
beach bag and my Hawaiian shirt Oh in
the bag the bag is really cute and I
think he was on a complete tear about
just picking up things that matched my
hair today I think that she can
definitely do a whole day in the city in
this outfit he's out and about in the
town a lot so I just think that she
needs to elevate her game because she's
out in the public all the time so it's
time to start being a little bit of a
grown-up oh God from the sunglasses to
the top today it is just just
well-coordinated me see now he's gonna
actually want to take me I'm a monster
it's all food backpack full of goodie
there's worth stuff I wanted you to have
something else because of all the hard
work you've been doing
you're beautiful okay sweetie thank you
thank you thank you appreciate it
now we have matching shades and we can
go out and stun on everybody